We know a fractional exponent represents power divided by root, so this first
one will be the cube root of r squared, we have r squared here since the power
is 2 and we take the third root since our denominator is 3. For our second
example, we take the 3rd root of 4x, we don't need to write this exponent of 1
in here since anything raised to the 1st power is the same expression, 4x to
the 1 really equals 4x. For this third one we also have power divided by root.
So we take the third root of this expression raised to the 4th power. You might
have distributed this 4th power to each of the factors inside of a radical. And
you would wind up with this radical. Either one is correct. It turns out that
we can simplify this radical but weren't getting into that yet. We're do that
in the next lesson. The other way you could have written the answer is like
this, you could have take the cube root of 5ab squared c and then raise that
quantity to the 4th power. We can take the root first and then raise the result
to the 4th power or we can raise this expression to the 4th power and then take
the 3rd root. This is true because the exponent of 4 and the exponent of one
third have the same priority in the order of operations. A root really
represents a type of exponent so we could do either exponent first.